WE ARE IN DAY TWO OF OUR
CONTINUING COVERAGE OF THE
UNREST IN BALTIMORE.
AND IT FEELS LIKE THERE'S
BEEN A LITTLE REST IN THE
UNREST IN THE LAST 24 HOURS.
BUT YOU KNOW, I CAUGHT
SOMETHING ON CNN LAST NIGHT
THAT REALLY STOOD OUT.
HERE'S A REPORT THAT AIRED
ABOUT TEN MINUTES AFTER THE
10 P.M. CURFEW.
SEE IF YOU NOTICE SOMETHING
MISSING FROM THIS PICTURE.
AND HINT, IT'S NOT MISSING
YET.
>> WOULD YOU HAVE DONE IT? DO
YOU THINK THAT IS THE RIGHT
THING?
>> THERE IS NO EASY ANSWER
TO THAT.
WHAT IT APPEARS TO BE THAT
BALTIMORE IS TRYING TO
DO-- IS DO SOMETHING A
LITTLE DIFFERENT HERE, NOT
BE AS CONFRONTATIONAL, BUT
OF COURSE, THEY KNOW THEY
GOT TO GET THE MISSION DONE.
>> OKAY, SO AT THIS POINT,
WHAT DO YOU DO?
DO YOU GO IN AND START
ARRESTING PEOPLE?
>> I THINK THEY DO JUST WHAT
THEY'RE DOING RIGHT NOW.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: DID YOU SEE THAT?
THE BROTHER JUST
DISAPPEARED.
YOU SAW THAT.
IT WAS A BROTHER WALKING
THERE, OKAY, WAIT, LET'S
WATCH IT ONE MORE TIME,
OKAY?
ALL RIGHT THERE IS THE PAST
CURFEW BROTHER, HE IS JUST
DOING A LITTLE HARMLESS COP
HASSLING.
LOOK AT THIS, THAT IS A HUM
V BLOCKING THE CAMERA.
GET OUT OF THE WAY, I CAN'T
SEE, I CAN'T SEE.
GET OUT-- OKAY, IT'S GONE.
OKAY, WHAT DID THEY DO TO
THE BROTHER?
HE IS GONE!
THE BROTHER'S JUST GONE!
OH MY GOD!
WHAT THE-- NOW THAT IS SOME
GANGSTA [BLEEP] RIGHT THERE,
MAN.
IF YOUR GANG IS CALLED THE
NATIONAL GUARD.
CALM DOWN, LARRY, CALM DOWN.
NOW IT LOOKS LIKE HE WAS
KIDNAPPED BUT IT TURNS OUT,
THE HUM V BLOCK OUR VIEW
WHILE THE POLICE ARRESTED
HIM AND TOOK HIM AWAY.
BUT THE STORY IS NOT
ABOUT THE POLICE ARRESTING A
GUY WHO WAS OUT PAST HIS
CURFEW, OKAY.
WE'RE TALKING SIMPLE OPTICS
HERE.
NOW GUYS, DO YOU NOT
REMEMBER THAT BALTIMORE
ERUPTED BECAUSE OF HOW A
YOUNG BLACK MAN WAS KILLED
IN A MYSTERIOUS POLICE VAN
RIDE.
THEN ON NATIONAL TELEVISION,
YOU HAVE A MYSTERIOUS POLICE
VEHICLE SHOW UP AND
DISAPPEAR ANOTHER BROTHER.
YOU KNOW, BALTIMORE, WHEN
YOU ARE UNDER ATTACK FROM
VIOLATIONS OF CIVIL RIGHTS
IT'S PROBABLY BEST NOT TO
MANAGE THEM LIKE SOME KLAN
RALLY MAGICIAN.
PRESTO CHANGEO NO MORE
NEGRO.
THAT IS JUST HORRIBLE OPTICS.
>> IT'S JUST WRONG. AND IT DOES
NOTHING TO HELP
REPAIR THE FRACTURED
RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN BLACK FOLKS AND THE
POLICE.
AND IT'S NOT JUST COPS.
DON'T WORRY, DON'T WORRY,
IT'S OKAY, IT'S OKAY, RELAX,
RELAX.
NOBODY IS GOING TO GET
DISAPPEARED, ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S JUST OUR IRONY ALERT.
THERE WE GO.
THE IRONY OF OUR IRONY ALERT
IS THAT IT TAKES A BEAT TO
COME UP.
ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT, OH, OH,
IRONY-- OKAY, HANG ON FOR
SOME DRIPPING IRONY FROM
FORMER BALTIMORE RAVENS
LINEBACKER RAY LEWIS.
>> NO WAY THIS CAN HAPPEN IN
OUR CITY.
GET OFF THE STREETS!
VIOLENCE IS NOT THE ANSWER.
VIOLATION HAS NEVER BEEN THE
ANSWER.
THAT'S RIGHT.
VIOLENCE HAS NEVER BEEN THE
ANSWER, ONCE-ACCUSED MURDERER
AND PROFESSIONAL CONCUSSION
GIVER, YOU ARE RIGHT.
NOW THE CITY IS TRYING TO
MOVE ON.
THERE ARE A LOT OF HOPEFUL
IMAGES.
MORE THAN 10,000 PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN PEACEFULLY PROTESTING.
EVEN OLDER CITIZENS HAVE
STOOD UP FOR THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS.
NOW LOOK, GUYS, I KNOW WE
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD AND
FOCUS ON THE FUTURE.
I GET THAT.
BUT I DON'T THINK WE CAN
FULLY MOVE FORWARD ON THIS
ISSUE UNTIL WE LOOK BACK.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW, WE'RE TIED
TO A-- LIKE A BIG-ASS ROCK
AND THE ROCK IS LIKE-- IT'S
A RACIST ROCK, WHICH-- NOW,
ITS-- OKAY, LOOK, THE
METAPHOR ISN'T IMPORTANT,
ALL RIGHT?
(LAUGHTER)
BUT WHAT IS IMPORTANT IS
THAT THERE ARE SOME VERY
REAL ISSUES THAT NEED TO GET
ADDRESSED BEFORE ANYONE
MOVES ON.
FOR INSTANCE, IT'S BEEN MORE
THAN TWO WEEKS AND WE STILL
DON'T HAVE ANSWERS ON WHAT
HAPPENED TO FREDDIE GRAY.
ONE FACT THAT HAS EMERGED IS
THAT HE WAS ONLY THE LATEST
PERSON TO GO TOE-TO-TOE WITH
THE BALTIMORE POLICE VAN AND
LOSE.
>> THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF
ATTENTION GIVEN TO WHAT HAS
BEEN CALLED QUOTE A ROUGH
RIDE.
>> A WOMAN SAYS COPS
HANDCUFFED HER.
THE DRIVER WAS SLAMMING ON
THE BRAKES TO RAM HER
AGAINST THE INSIDE OF THE
VEHICLE.
>> I TELL YOU WHEN A COP IS
SLAMMING ME AROUND IN THE
BLACK OF THE POLICE VAN
TRYING TO SERIOUSLY INJURE
ME, THAT DRIVER IS
DEFINITELY ONLY GET GETTING
TWO STARS.
DAMMIT, THAT'S UBER. IT WOULD BE
COOL IF WE WERE ABLE TO RATE
COPS IN AN APP, THOUGH. IT IS
HARD TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT YOUR ROUGH
RIDE WHEN YOUR DRIVER HAS, I
DON'T KNOW, KILLED YOU?
>> BALTIMORE POLICE ARRESTED
A MAN FOR PUBLIC URINATION
IN 2005.
DIDN'T BUCKLE HIS SEAT BELT,
THEN TOOK A HARD TURN.
DOCTORS SAY HIS SPINE WAS
DISLOCATED.
HE LATER DIED.
>> Larry: THIS IS DISGUSTING,
GUYS.
AND THIS IS THE EXACT SAME
THING THAT HAPPENED TO
FREDDIE GRAY, TEN YEARS
LATER.
LOOK BALTIMORE POLICE,
KILLING PEOPLE IN THE VAN IS
NOT THE SPIDER-MAN ORIGIN
STORY, YOU DO NOT NEED TO DO A
GRITTY REBOOT EVERY FEW YEARS,
ACTUALLY HOLLYWOOD, THAT
GOES FOR THE ACTUAL
SPIDER-MAN ORIGIN STORY,
WHILE WE'RE AT IT.
APPARENTLY BALTIMORE HAS HAD
TO PAY OUT A TON OF MONEY
BECAUSE THEY JUST CAN'T STOP
MISCONDUCTING.
>> THE CITY HAS MADE MORE
THAN $5.7 MILLION DOLLARS IN
JUDGEMENTS AND SETTLEMENTS
FOR ALLEGED POLICE
MISCONDUCT.
>> THIS INCLUDES SIX FIGURE
SETTLEMENTS FOR ALLEGEDLY
SLAMMING A PREGNANT WOMAN TO
THE GROUND.
FOR KILLING AN UNARMED
MARINE VETERAN.
AND FOR BEATING A CHURCH
DEACON.
>> Larry: JESUS, BALTIMORE
PD, A PREGNANT WOMAN, A VET
AND A CHURCH DEACON?
THAT IS LIKE THE HOLY
TRINITY OF SYMPATHETIC
VICTIMS.
WHY NOT SHUT DOWN THE
SPECIAL OLYMPICS FOR NOISE
VIOLATION AND MAKE IT AN
EVEN FOUR.
GOOD LORD.
I CAN'T EVEN BELIEVE THIS.
NOW LOOK, THE PROBLEMS WITH
THE POLICE ARE VERY BAD.
BUT IT IS JUST ONE ITEM ON
THE LIST.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IN
THIS AREA IS 52 PERCENT,
AND THE MEDIUM INCOME IN
FREDDIE GRAY'S NEIGHBORHOOD IS
$250 BELOW THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LINE.
THIS NEIGHBORHOOD DOESN'T JUST
WANT TO MOVE UP TO A DELUXE
APARTMENT IN THE SKY, JUST
MOVE ON UP TO BEING ABLE TO
FEED THEIR KIDS. AND UNTIL
WE CAN DISAPPEAR SOME OF
THESE STATISTICS, AIN'T
NOBODY MOVING ON.